antonio senzatella here he comes out of
the first base dugout on the trot
headed to the mound above 70 degrees
that is live right at the third baseman
josh fuentes one out
pitch is hit up the middle grabbed by
story on the line
and the runners get back as trev
dove and caught that liner just above
the dirt
then he faced him twice in september and
shut him down muncie yanks it base it
into center field
that'll drive home corey seeger for the
first run of the day
two out rbi single max muncie the
dodgers lead at one nothing
on that play at the plate but dave
roberts expects him to be back in there
tomorrow
smith with a line drive that's another
base hit and it's two nothing dodgers
spraying line drives all over the place
in this first inning but no real fly
balls either these are like humpback
liners or solid line drives like this
one off the bat of will smith
it's a competition right now to see who
can hit it the hardest on the line
pitching tonight it'll be trevor bauer
the reigning cy young award winner in
the national league making his dodger
debut last year the acquired mookie bets
the best position player available well
trevor bauer the best free agent pitcher
available so this is fantastic to have
him make his dodger debut a little bit
of a challenge in coors field
tapia hits one in the air to left center
field cody bellinger back with room shy
of the track one gone
slider gets a chase two up
his first strikeout in the dodger
uniform
fastball's been around 92 to 96.
so when you talk slider
you're talking about a bigger breaking
slaughter on one two
missed his spot diving stop gavin looks
what a play
that's the best defensive play of his
young big league career and that's a
smile you're gonna see more and more of
as he gains more and more experience
the 1-2
seeger with a fly ball to right field
blackman going back he can't get it it's
over his head one hop to the wall beds
will score seeger is at second base he's
two for two and the dodgers take a three
to nothing lead
on a one-one pitch turner weights and a
breaking ball serves it in the center
here comes owings lays out and can't get
it and it gets by blackman
three consecutive two out extra base
hits and it's four nothing
bets seeger and turner all with two out
doubles
as blackman
drills one into center field and running
it down is
cody bellinger like a wide receiver
on the fly pattern he tracks it down
blackman's retired first out of the
second
puts an exponential quotient on each one
gets owings to chase for strike three
one-two pitch struck him out with a fast
ball that splits the plate
third one for bauer two away in the
third
brings another one-two to tapia and
spikes him out with a cutter
and they exchange a stair topia
staring back at bauer who returns it in
his direction and then steps off of the
field
bauer on owen two squares to bunt in
front of the plate good job throws to
first bauer's retired
and lux goes to second on the sacrifice
2-3
and the dirt kicks away from nunez and
both runners advance
definitely did not want to throw him a
strike and if it was he was trying to
trick him for sure
four pitch walk and they're loaded for
turn
base hit right field for turner who is
three for three
lux and bets both into score the dodgers
lead six nothing
we talked about justin when we did the
little vignette on him how he can
kind of slice the ball over to right
field well this one he carves over there
beats the defense gets the rbis
continues to keep the line moving
and now sends a teller who pitched
around a lefty to get to a righty even
in more trouble with
two real good left-handed hitters coming
up
bellinger swings in the first pitch
roller to second
4-6 almost but bellinger beats it out
and seeger comes in
so they lead it seven nothing as
bellinger legs that one out
that's exactly what he does to strike
out story
the fifth for bauer two gone in the
fourth
[Music]
finds his way back into the count once
he gets there he dots it on the corner
then he walks him off with a great check
swing from a top hitter in the league
misses with a fastball but gets it for a
foul ball
throws a cutter and gets another foul
ball but then tunnels his way right to
the slider and the strikeout
fifth leading from second base
and there's a liner in the right center
field a diving stab by blackman he can't
get it gets past him
rolls to the wall owings picks it up
throw coming in too late in the score is
smith lux arrives at third and the
dodgers lead eight to nothing
now the o2
swung on and missed strike three power
strikes out mcmahon
sixth strike out of the game for trevor
bauer 02.
struck him out with the slider owens
tipped his cap
striker number seven for trevor bauer
and two gone in the fifth
eight strikeouts for trevor bauer
five innings and no hits against him and
his first strut in dodger blue
can maintain his velocity and his
movement
on the hands of hillard short left field
seeger's out to put it away for the
first down of the six
[Music]
soft roller luxe's second two up and two
down in the
six a wide array of ground balls
now the one-two swung on in missed
strike three on a slider down and away
bauer's ninth strikeout of the night
he is on fire
his second successful sacrifice tonight
this one brings home will smith
luke is waiting for him to keep on
running but pollock's gonna hang on his
second
part of the order here for the rockies
trevor story
yanks the first pitch that he sees in
the left base hill
so the no hitter broken up to lead off
the seventh on a single
[Applause]
this ball's driven to deep right field
way back and god
charlie blackman
with the rocky's first homer of the year
a two-run shot here in the seventh
against bauer
uh-oh this ball lifted high and deep
right field it's got a chance to go
ryan mcmahon with a two-run home run
get some swinging his 10th strikeout of
the night
and nunez hits a towering fly ball deep
right center field this one's going to
fly how about this inning for the
rockies
certainly
take a good look you won't see this one
for long off the facade of the second
deck
sam hilliard oh my gosh there's a cap
[Applause]
swinging to the first pitch ground ball
to first muncie to the bag and the
dodgers are in the win column in 2021
11-6 over the rockies here in game two